I wasn't sure whether but the little
voice recordings the answering machine
bit what are they from Donnie Darko it's
basically a feature with Jake Gyllenhaal
we got permission yeah I don't just Nick
him yeah he actually recorded it Wow
yeah it's amazing really lovely of him
really all the legal stuff oh I don't
know too much about our just think it's
a it's a licensing thing with the movie
studios oh so it'll cost a fortune
yeah yeah it's traumatic yeah it's very
dramatic and I'm so happy to bring out
our depressions on Valentine's Day
because I hate this day
Renard now you've met something good
before you met and where did you meet
Anna
well I'm if you didn't remember I would
certainly forgive you but I meant you
had a very momentous moment for you you
won I was backstage at the Grammys
getting ready to present whatever the
hell I was presenting and you had just
won Best New Artist at the Grammys and
Sam comes backstage and is kind of going
do you know where I'm supposed to go I'm
so like just blown away in this moment
that like a person can win Best New
Artist at the Grammys and you think that
they go offstage into just a pool of
diamonds and roses and instead it's just
me I saw you in inter direction and an
OT you've met sound before yeah do you
know
let me just say so I'm very new to this
whole world so whenever you meet famous
people I was like a girl from South
Africa you you I freaked out
I freaked out and so I saw them and I
was with Daisy Lowe and we were out and
I was like when I see them I'm gonna
remain calm I'm gonna be like hi Sam
it's so nice to meet you I love your
music and I always starts to it on
Strictly so this is like come on come on
come on I'll introduce you I got there
and I said hi Sam and then I started
doing the running man out
[Applause]
know what said Sam Smith running man do
it right so Sam's got a the new album on
the first of May and Justin are you
planning more new music is this so much
okay
no you really know I I'm always in the
studio so yeah maybe soon
[Applause]
[Music]
you